schools across the valley are not
letting virtual learning get in the way
of celebrating black history month
democracy prep has several events
planned to honor the important
contribution of african americans
bianca holman is live this morning from
the school's west side campus with that
story bianca good morning
hey good morning john so like most
schools democracy prep is finding
creative ways to still
uh have students learn about black
history month so this week they've got a
spirit week and one of those days i'm
excited to say is dedicated to
historically black
colleges and universities and of course
i had to represent howard university
it's a bison not not the buffalo bills
it's a bison there you guys howard
university in washington d.c so
they've got things planned all month
long and for those that don't know a
little bit more about democracy prep
it's a k
through 12 charter school here in the
historic west side
they've got a few other cultural days
planned like a day for traditional
african attire
in the second week they've got a talent
showcase and some of the art teachers
they're incorporating lessons about key
moments in black history
like the harlem renaissance and we spoke
with the executive director adam johnson
and he tells us
inclusion and learning about diverse
cultures are important
he says they want students to learn
about black scientists businessmen and
women
and doctors the impression really is
is to help scholars understand that the
history of
of black people in america runs very
deep
and that we've really had an impact
on a variety of industry
in our country in 1920
and so here are some helpful
kid-friendly resources to talk about
black history at home
the first you may be familiar with
scholastic.com remember they have those
book fairs
they've got a few printable lesson plans
where you they talk about
popular inventors black inventors and
less famous civil rights figures like
melvitio of the little rock nine and
then there's another website i am home
school network they have a list of 45
recommendations including some
documentaries that kids can watch
and finally the national museum of
african american history in washington
d.c
has a tab for students to learn about
black engineers and
inventors as well and those in tech and
so coming up in the next half hour we're
going to talk with one of democracy prep
students about
what this month means to them reporting
live bianca holman 8 news now bianca
thank you very much